If you're a reborn Christian and you
say, well, I don't have self-control,
then in a sense you're right because we all
have that sinful fleshly nature within us.
And it's going to be there until the
day we die and it pushes us to do sin
like overeating, gluttony, getting angry
and quarrel, or not study, but be lazy.
It is that fleshly nature
within you that brings you down.
But you see, if you are a true reborn Christian,
you have received a new spiritual nature.
God Himself, the Holy Spirit,
came and lives inside of you.
You see, there is a change and now
you can choose to live through the
Spirit and the Spirit can overcome the flesh.
And it is the only power that
can overcome the sinful nature.